hello everybody uh and welcome to
uh this presentation on legal and
regulatory developments affecting
molecular testing uh my name is peter
kaizon i'm an attorney in the firm of
allston and byrd
in
washington dc although actually today
i'm talking to you from the very tip of
cape cod
uh it's a pleasure to be here with you
today
um
the
this presentation today is maybe a
little bit different than some of the
other presentations that you may be
attending uh because this is looking at
the legal and regulatory issues that
affect all of the incredible new
developments and discoveries
that you folks are all working on
the idea of course being that as
wonderful as these things are you may at
some point want to be
either paid for them or try and build
for them or try and commercialize them
and
at least in the united states there are
an incredible number of regulatory
hurdles that you have to be aware of
and this happens to be an area which is
changing just exponentially even as we
as even as we speak about it so the idea
is to try and give you some of an
overview of what are the various legal
and regulatory issues that are affecting
this sort of testing and things that you
want to be aware of as you're developing
it
and so our agenda today is to talk about
some of those key
regulatory and reimbursement issues and
and they fall into certain basic
categories one is uh what the fda is
doing the fda of course being the
primary regulatory agency that affects
uh all medical devices and drugs in the
united states
uh how these things are being built and
coded because coding obviously affects
everything else in terms of how things
are being paid
uh and there are some very significant
changes that are going on now in terms
of how lab laboratory testing is going
to be reimbursed over the next uh
over the next few years
uh and we're going to be talking about
that in particular
every year
medicare
has to has to do a um has to adjust what
it will pay for physician services in
the coming year which is based on a
formula that we refer to as the sgr or
sustainable growth rate formula
that bill that
uh that formula is basically changed
every year because if not physicians
would
uh receive a very large cut and we refer
to that usually as the physician fee
patch legislation
this year when congress did that patch
they included some provisions that
affect clinical laboratory testing that
are going to be very significant
and the tech in
the
payment area in particular we'll be
focusing on medicare because that's the
largest payer but what medicare does
basically tends to affect everything
across the board
so the first thing that we're going to
want to talk about are are the fda
issues the food and drug administration
is the us agency that regulates drugs
food and medical devices
uh and laboratory tests at least in some
areas are considered medical devices
when a
when a
manufacturer creates a kit that then is
sold to laboratories that is used to
perform a particular type of test
that kit is considered a medical device
and it has to go through an fda
uh approval or clearance process
most of the types of tests that that
we're thinking about today in terms of
genetic tests and molecular tests aren't
really done as kits they're really done
as something that are called laboratory
developed tests
and laboratory developed tests are tests
that are developed within an individual
laboratory and for use within that
laboratory they're not the the actual uh
kit itself by which the test is done
is not sold uh in commerce and sold to
other laboratories
historically the fda has not regulated
laboratory developed tests we used to
call them homebrew tests
nomenclature we don't really use as much
anymore
so if a test qualifies as a laboratory
developed test then the fda says it
exercises its enforcement discretion and
is and does not regulate that test
doesn't require the manufacturer to
register with the fda and doesn't
require that the
tests go through a pre-market approval
clearance or process
um
however that restriction or that
exemption is somewhat limited and the
fda has taken action against
against products that he believes
uh are not
uh really laboratory developed tests and
really shouldn't be going through the
fda process
um but the fda has noted that it is
beginning to have some concerns about
the use of this exemption and obviously
it's a great benefit to a to somebody
who's developing a laboratory test not
to have to go through the fda approval
process saves a lot of time and saves a
lot of money
uh in 2007 the fda first suggested that
it might begin to regulate laboratory
developed tests
and
it looked at a particular sort of test
that it called
in vitro devices multivariate index
assays or ibd mias
and those are tests that use a
particular algorithm
and and
look at the results from various
biomarkers put them through that
algorithm and then come up with a an
index or
something that that predicts uh what a
clinical result will be
um
the fda did two drafts of guidances with
regard to these but it never finalized
them
and in 2010 it announced that it was
looking at a more comprehensive approach
and instead decided it would regulate
all of ldt's regardless of whether they
were ibd mias or some
or something less
uh elaborate
uh and in 2010 it said that we are
committed to doing this and regulating
ldt's although the type of regulation
still is not clear
uh
fda continues to state that it is its
intention to regulate laboratory
developed tests
it is probably the worst kept secret in
washington that the fda has drafted
three different draft guidances
and
one dealing with sort of the general
regulatory framework
one addressing whether or not
registration or notice is required and
one looking at how the fda requirements
and the clear requirements
are
can be harmonized clear is the broad
quality control regulation that applies
to all clinical laboratories
um
those guidances are believed to be
finalized they are it is
widely believed that they are
being reviewed now by the office of
management and budget which has to
review all of these types of guidances
and
and they seem to be
kind of held up there or are getting
pretty close review there
so no one knows for sure when these
draft guidances um
will be issued or if in fact they will
ever be issued
but
despite the uh the fact that the
laboratory developed test guidances
haven't been issued uh the fda has taken
a lot of other actions in this area
that
will reach many of the sorts of
molecular diagnostic tests that i'm sure
many of you are developing
probably one of the most important areas
is in the area of what are called
companion diagnostics
companion diagnostics are those tests
where the diagnostic is used to
determine
uh
who is a candidate for a particular test
that i'm sorry for a particular drug or
therapeutic product
obviously her2 new and herceptin are the
best examples of this uh in order to
determine whether someone uh should be
receiving herceptin you do her two new
first to determine uh whether or not the
drug is likely to be effective for them
and so the fda has said we expect that
it expects more and more tests to be and
products to be developed with a
companion diagnostic test
uh now with regard to this the fda has
said this this isn't just a test like
cholesterol that's useful in determining
whether or not
uh
you know you should be on crestor or
something like that
and it also has recognized that for
certain products
where
for where there may be a novel or a rare
use
it may be difficult for that to be
developed but basically the fda has said
it expects in the future that more and
more drugs and we're talking primarily
about oncology drugs in this area
will also have a companion diagnostic
that helps to
predict who in who the particular drug
will be useful for
uh the fda issued a draft guidance
several years ago on companion
diagnostics
and the final guidance is expected at
any time
and fda has said it is a high priority
for 2014.
they said the same thing for 2013 though
so it may
it may still be a little bit of time
what's
significant about this though is many of
the tests that we're talking about is
laboratory developed tests are in fact
used as companion diagnostics that is
they are tested or developed to help
predict what uh
what types of therapies may be effective
in a particular individual and so
if the fda comes out with guidance that
requires
that fda that
that the companion diagnostic the fda
approved or cleared
that will have an impact on a large
number of laboratory developed tests
the other area in which the fda has
taken action uh and that has some impact
on the sorts of tests that we're talking
about today
deals with those tests that are labeled
as research use only or investigational
use only
in in often in the past
uh
some manufacturers would label their
products in this way either rule or iuo
uh
which means that they are not intended
to be used for clinical purposes
even though there was an acknowledgement
of sort of a tacit understanding that in
fact the laboratory was going to take
these particular products and use them
as
uh
and use them for their for clinical
purposes
the fda felt that was a invasion of
their rules and regulations
and
came down with their rule iuo guidance
in which it said
that they were concerned about this that
manufacturers had to take steps to make
sure that basically
um
that that the
ivds were not being misused
you could not for example as a
manufacturer say here is a product
that's our ulyu but here's how you would
use it in a particular clinical purpose
uh you couldn't include statements for
example that say
that clinical laboratories could
validate the test through their own
procedures and then offer
uh the test as a laboratory-developed
test
um
and if the lab if the manufacturer knew
or had reason to know that the
laboratory really wasn't was going to
use it in a clinical use or for example
um
didn't do any research or investigation
then
it might be liable
for selling the product in that
particular instance and it would also uh
it would also come under fda scrutiny if
it offered support to the laboratory for
a particular clinical purpose so even
though the fda has not issued the
laboratory-developed test guidance that
supposedly is in the pipeline there are
another number of other ways in which
they can reach
many of the diagnostic tests that we're
talking about
under these other regulatory initiatives
and the fda has as we've said taken some
action against other sorts of tests
where it thinks um
they do not meet regulatory requirements
the most uh significant one is probably
the action that it took against 23andme
which is a company that offers direct to
consumer genetic testing
and the fda had alleged that
the fda that the company had not
adequately validated the testing that it
was offering
and basically sent a cease and desist
letter to the company
uh telling it that it couldn't market
these tests anymore
and what's significant about the 23andme
um
uh process uh or initiative is
that basically it's
in the letter that the fda sent
it said that the company had met with
the fda on numerous occasions that that
the company said it was in fact
validating uh the tests that it was
doing that it was offering to consumers
uh and then
and then
took no further action after that
the fda has a history of looking very
closely at any instance where something
is is marketed as a direct to consumer
test
uh because i it feels that there is a
real possibility of abuse in that
situation
and so
as a result
of the fda's action
the 23andme has stopped offering its
genetic testing uh it's the testing is
still available but it's really only
done to do ancestry testing at this
point in time
so that takes us through sort of the
variety of actions that the fda is
taking with regard
to the types of tests that were we are
talking about
so the next area that we're going to
move into then is okay if you get
through maybe you have a laboratory
developed test maybe you've gone through
the fda process but now how do you get
to bill and get paid for this test
and molecular diagnostic tests have a a
very um
uh kind of tortured and complicated
history
and it's important to understand a
little bit about coding because that
affects how these things are now getting
paid for and some of the issues that are
going on now with regard to uh building
a payment policy
so until 2013 most molecular diagnostic
tests were built using what are called
stacking codes and that is that each
separate piece of the process was coded
separately so you would build for the
extraction of dna the amplification of
the dna the interpretation of the result
and each step in that process uh was
built separately and often there were
several different units of each step
that were built so you might have
uh you know 20 different
multiples of the amplification step for
example
but
nothing was specific about the
individual type of
analyte that was being looked at so when
that test was billed for
the payer didn't know whether it was a
braf test or a her2 new test or a
bcr able because they all looked the
same
on the payment side all you were doing
was billing for the steps and so payers
including medicare complained they
didn't know what they were paying for
because the analyte wasn't identified
and they had no way to judge the medical
necessity of the particular test that
they were doing so they didn't know what
whether this was a b raft test or a k
rasp or some other test genetic test
that maybe uh didn't have the same
clinical utility as one of these other
tests
at the same time as this
as as these new tests were being
developed and these stacking codes were
being used
one of the medicare contractors palmetto
which is the the contractor that
processes claims
for well now it does it for north
carolina south carolina and virginia but
at
several years ago it also had california
and nevada
and where a number of these tests were
being done and palmetto developed a
special program by which it would get
around this issue of not knowing what
tests would be built for and it was it
required that all tests being of
molecular
tests being done
go through a process and get a
particular identifier
uh
that would be put on the claim when the
test was built so that palmetto could
recognize what the test was is it a
b-ras b-raf is k-ras is it something
else
and you got that code either through
palmetto or you got it through uh
mckesson diagnostics which has a a
diagnostics process by which it assigns
codes to these sorts of tests
if you've got if you tried to submit a a
code and a
claim for a molecular diagnostic test
and you didn't have one of these codes
the claim was rejected
and in addition tess had to go through a
technical assessment process prior to
being paid by palmetto so once it knew
what the test was it would then say okay
now we want to look at the evidence
regarding this particular test and see
what support there is for
that voldex program still is going on in
california it's also been expanded to
north carolina and south carolina and
the key
issue is really
to what extent that program gets
expanded
to other jurisdictions
and and also whether or not other payers
pick it up
so
that was the process until about 2011
when concern about the the fact that
there was no transparency to these codes
finally percolated up to the ama
and at that point the ama developed some
new cpt codes
that were more specific
and so they got rid of the old stacking
codes and and other codes such as what
are called not otherwise classified
codes or miscellaneous codes which were
built used to build many molecular
diagnostic tests
and instead there were specific codes
now for some of the most common
molecular diagnostic tests including uh
k-ras b-raf
rock one and two um and they're
basically over a hundred new codes there
are also some what are called tier two
codes which are more general procedure
based codes which kind of lump a variety
of similar
less frequently performed tests together
so and and what this does is it allows
greater transparency
uh to payers about what test is actually
being performed because now they're
being billed for a with a cpt code for a
particular test
and they know what the analyte is
now when you get new codes that has an
impact on pricing because obviously
everything is is priced according to a
particular code
so medicare didn't use and most payers
didn't use these new codes in 2012 when
they became effective because they
needed more time to observe it
and medicare had a couple of key issues
that it had to try and determine
one is how to pay for these medicare
pays for laboratory testing in two
different ways
one it has the physician fee schedule
which is a
process that is updated annually
and looks at the physician work uh and
the
uh practice expense involved with doing
a physician service and the other is the
clinical laboratory fee schedule which
is a uh a fee schedule that is was
originally set based in 1984 and is
periodically updated
um
and so one question was which
methodology do you use to pay for it and
secondly if it was going to be on the
clinical fee schedule
there are different ways that new tests
are being set
uh the prices for tests are being set so
there's a question of how that's being
done
uh in 2012 cms through its rulemaking
process announced that it believed that
these tests should be on the clinical fp
schedule which is where they had always
been before uh and and cms basically
said
it wasn't convinced that there was
always a need for
a physician to actually do the
interpretation of these tests
and secondly it would pay for them using
what is called the gap-filling process
which we're going to talk about in a
second
cms did create a
an interpretation code
um which is valued at about 18 which it
said laboratories could use where there
was a medically necessary reason for a
physician to come in and do the
interpretation
now as i said these tests were going to
be priced using what's called the gap
filling method and basically what gap
filling is is a way for medic the
medicare program to go out to its
various contractors who
process laboratory claims and
all claims for medicare medical services
and basically says it's medicare
assessors contractors we don't really
know what the right price is for these
you
uh
see what you
contractors develop a price
uh that you think is appropriate and you
can do that based on what the costs are
what is paid for what other payers are
paying for them
uh any other information that you may be
able to gather
there's a fairly lengthy process that
went through
the laboratory has been through in 2013
about
these particular tests in which um
the the
prices uh i'm sorry in which the tests
were priced and first the contractors
come up with prices
uh then there's an opportunity to
comment on those prices then at the end
of last year cms takes these
uh all the various uh payment amounts
and
um
and looks at what the median is of them
because and that median becomes the
price going forward
and it went through that process in
uh 2013
developed the
median of all the carrier specific
prices those became the new prices for
2014.
there was one
glitch sort of in this whole process so
as
this process continued
medicare published the the prices and
then there's an opportunity to to
comment on them so
medicare price uh published the final
prices in november of 2013
um
and then came up with with the final
prices after that
um
i'm sorry it published the final prices
in september there's an opportunity to
comment and then the final prices come
out in november and uh basically there
was no change in any of those prices
between september and november
with the exception of the price for
bronco one and two
and it was reduced by about thirteen
hundred dollars which obviously was was
fairly significant
and this appears to be a decision that
cms made on its own
partly because of the fact that in the
summer the supreme court had decided
that other laboratories that that it was
not permissible
for myriad to patent
uh the the test the dna that was used
for the broccoli test at least
that's that's part of the decision they
could patent other processes but not the
actual dna process itself
and see i think there is some concern
that cms thought that
others would be uh
offering the same test and therefore the
price might go down
um and so it cut the reimbursement
between september and november there was
another several other comment periods
and finally april 1st of this year
cms announced that based on all of the
comments it had gotten it was raising
the price didn't not the full thirteen
hundred dollars that it had reduced it
uh but it raised the price to about
twenty two hundred dollars uh which was
uh still a pretty sizable increase
but
based on that
with that
addition
all of the prices that were established
through gap filling uh during the 2013
process are now uh established and not
have established prices uh
beginning in 2014.
the other significant thing that
happened as part of this process is
in addition to pricing these contractors
were now looking much more closely at
what it is that they were paying for
and
now they could actually see
what the test was
and in a number of instances and
palmetto was probably the
the leader in all of this
began to request evidence that would
show the clinical validity of the
clinical utility of the particular test
um
and if that evidence wasn't sufficient
then
they would not pay for the test and in a
lot of instances contractors
decided not to pay for certain tests
that had been around for quite some time
because it felt that they were lacking
the
any evidence of medical necessity or
clinical utility
so that's been the other side of this
whole gap-filling process is a greater
scrutiny of what tests are being offered
so if you're often if you are developing
tests in this area it's very important
to be able to show uh have evidence that
you can present the contractors that
show
um the clinical utility of a particular
test that is not only that the test
works but that it does something useful
that physicians
use it in a way that affects outcomes
that's a that's a very high bar for a
lot of laboratory tests or diagnostic
tests generally
one other area to bear in mind here is
what are called ma tests
ma stands for molecular assays with
algorithmic analysis
these are
like the molecular tests but a little
bit different
these are tested use an algorithm and
apply that algorithm to multiple results
from different assays that result in a
numeric score or an index so tests like
the
agenda mammoprint or the
genomic health oncotype dx are examples
of this
that is they are situations where
you the laboratory looks at a variety of
different biomarkers puts them through
those biomarkers through a particular
algorithm and is able to predict
whether a cancer will occur or whether
someone is
a good candidate for a particular
therapy something like that
most of these tests
today don't have their own cpt code
there's they're
unique to an individual manufacturer or
laboratory and they are built using what
are called
noc or not otherwise classified codes
medicare has had a lot of trouble
deciding how it is how it will build for
these particular tests
or how it will pay for these particular
law tests
initially cms said it actually wouldn't
recognize the medicare codes
it said that they were
and the reason for this is because it
looked at them as
basically as calculations
uh and medicare doesn't pay for
calculations um
in the usual sense that is if you have a
cholesterol and an hdl and you calculate
the ldl
medicare doesn't pay for that
calculation because
it's deemed uh
you know too obvious or something that
the physician can almost do themselves
cms looked at these algorithms and felt
that they were similar in some way to
these sorts of calculations even though
they're far more complex physicians
really can't
um
make these kind of calculations
themselves like they could for other
sorts of tests
uh
and cms was concerned that there really
was no clear definition
of what what these tests were and so how
it could
sort of make a categorical statement of
whether or not they should be covered
after a lot of
uh education from the industry and a lot
of pressure cms
eventually said last year
it would permit contractors to make the
determination of whether or not to pay
for these tests
uh assuming that they could show
clinical validity clinical utility so
cms kind of
stepped out of it kind of bucked it to
the contractors um which made sense and
actually contractors were already paying
for a number of these tests so that
seemed like an appropriate way to go
forward
um
there are a variety of different changes
that are happening now
in this area involving
involving molecular diagnostic tests
one that's just kind of significant i
want to
just kind of mention because it suggests
how complicated this is
tests that are being used in a hospital
for a hospital in patients or
outpatients
don't get paid under
uh don't get paid directly by medicare
in fact those get paid as part of a
bundled payment that goes to the
hospital so it's
often happens when clients come to us
and say okay i have this great test i'm
going to get paid for it you say when is
it done i said well it's done in the
hospital
with a particular patient or an
outpatient basis he said well you're not
going to get paid anything by the
medicare program you're going to have to
build a hospital and the hospital is
then going to get paid this public
payment which affects then
uh
because it's a bundled payment that the
hospital is getting basically a
complicated payment that can affect uh
the hospital's ability to use a
particular test
uh and
in beginning in 2014
cms not only is bundling those inpatient
those laboratories into the inpatient
payment but it's beginning off now also
to pay
hospitals
on an outpatient basis
it's bundling those tests together as
well now it didn't make an exception for
molecular pathology tests so those can
still get paid separately
excuse me but there is a lot of
confusion around these requirements and
it's not totally clear which test cms is
going to pay for separately so it's an
important area to watch
now you'll also recall that in the
beginning of this i said that the
physician fee schedule was updated every
year but the clinton but under the
clinical app fee schedule was
established in 1984
and basically
was not uh
was not adjusted
frequently it was basically adjusted to
accomplish inflation
in some
actually relatively rare circumstances
so in most cases actually
even though the
fee schedule was supposed to be updated
to reflect inflation
congress didn't allow that
adjustment to go forward
because it determined that it needed
that
amount for budget savings it's kind of
the crazy way that that things are done
in washington
um
but
last year or and with the idea that it
would take place this year
medicare announced for the first time
that it was going to begin to adjust
pricing to reflect technological changes
that had occurred since this the lab
feature schedule was first developed
so
the proposal was
um
to re to look at
maybe 100 codes or 200 codes a year look
at how the cost of doing those tests had
changed since 1984 and adjust them going
forward
and that would be done every year
there's a lot of concern about this
particular proposal
especially after the gap filling process
a lot of labs felt that uh
there were no controls on this that
medicare would just sort of cut
indiscriminately and this could have a
tremendous impact
on
laboratories that we do this sort of
testing
so
that was
sorry
so that there was a lot of concern about
that
this particular provision actually was
eliminated as a result of this new sgr
patch that we talked about so partly out
of the concerns about
what this would mean
uh and after discussions with congress
and and because i think congress was
ready to change how laboratory testing
was paid for anyway
uh this process this particular
provision was now eliminated uh and will
not go forward
now as i said though there are some
pretty significant changes
um
that were made in and that will affect
laboratory reimbursement
going forward
and as i said each year
under the physician fee schedule the
physician fee schedule is
is modified or
adjusted each year based on a formula
that's called the sustainable growth
rate
and partly because of of
imperfections in the way that formula
was established
each year when cms
goes through that process they
find that the formula
would
if nothing was done
require a significant cut in physician
fees for the next year
so every year at the end of the year
congress steps in
and overrules its own formula through
the sgr
uh and
comes up with a a new adjustment
uh going forward so that physicians
don't get the cut that otherwise they
would be
they would have to
suffer with
now when that happens congress puts
other things in that and one of the
things that they put in the most recent
bill
was a provision that adjusts uh or
changes how clinical lab testing is is
paid for
um
and i and that arose
number one out of the fact that there
were
medicare gets the abstract congress then
can score savings from that that is this
the cost of this sgr patch has to be
offset by other savings and so there are
savings to doing what it did but also
because
several influential people in congress
decided that it was time to now go and
look at the lab fee schedule and come up
with a more appropriate way of doing it
so
the new approach is to base it on market
pricing that is what are third-party
payers paying in the market
uh it got rid of this technological
adjustment authority
that we had talked about previously that
cms was planning to use as a way of
utilizing the fee schedule
so i think it's important to just
understand a little bit about how this
process will work because it's going to
have a tremendous impact on how
laboratory tests are paid for going
forward and even though this only
affects medicare
most private payers follow in some way
or other what medicare does so if
medicare adjusts its payments you can
expect that third-party payers will also
adjust what they're doing
so beginning in 2016 labs will have to
report their pricing for third-party
payers and the volumes to cns so they
will have to report the prices from
private payers
from third-party payers medicare
advantage plans and medicaid managed
care plans
uh the process by which is this has got
to be done is still being developed
uh but the but the way the law is
written it requires
that each price paid by each payer over
this over a set time period be reported
so even if
uh payers change their payments over a
particular time period each each
the price that was paid and the volume
that was paid at each price will have to
be reported
um
the pricing these are this reporting is
done every three years but what are
called advanced diagnostic laboratory
tests which we'll talk about in a minute
or adlts those have to be reported every
year
and cms will have to come up with a rule
to talk about how this data process
works uh by june 2015.
so once all of that information uh is is
given to cms
it will
take all of the information the pricing
information as well as as well as the
volumes and determine a weighted median
for each individual cpt code based on
all of the reported prices now there's a
lot of talk about this
because basically what you're going to
be seeing is because of
this cms is going to be receiving if
they do it the way the law is written a
tremendous volume of information i mean
labs do
you know tens of thousands to hundreds
and thousands of tests
uh over a certain period so this is it's
going to be a tremendous
data dump uh on cms
uh and then based on all that
information they will have to calculate
a weighted mean
now the prices will be phased in over
time so that rather than
if it cms calculates a new median
or a new price going forward
that price um
is not
uh won't go into effect all at the same
time it'll be phased in 10 a year for
2017 through 2019 and then 15
after that assuming that that you know
it already captured all the
the required change
and so basically the changes won't be
fully implemented until 2022
now
as i said there are new provisions uh
there are also provisions related to new
tests as well as adlts
so
new tests
are those tests that aren't adl keys and
we'll talk about those more in a sec
and but basically when a test gets a new
cpt code
uh
it will it will be considered a new test
and so initially
cms will set the price either through
the gap filling or the crosswalk process
just as they were today
then
after the next reporting period they'll
be paid at the new market price
rather than the
the gap filling or the crosswalk price
now
cms there there is also a new advisory
panel that is established by the law
uh which is to include experts in the in
the laboratory field
that is supposed to make recommendations
about how tests are paid for that is
whether they should be gap-filled or
cross-walked
and if so what the correct price is
they also are allowed to have some
impact on coverage uh although that
piece is not quite as clear
in the way
and
cms has to explain how it applied the
various criteria dealing with gap
filling and crosswalking
uh when it determines the payment rates
there was a lot of concern during the
gap filling process
that went on in 2013
that the process was very opaque and
that most people couldn't understand
how the particular
how the prices were being arrived at so
this is to require
a greater explanation for how cms is
arriving at particular prices
now with the other
uh
type of test here
is what are called the adlts or advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests
and this definition basically
is to deal with the tests like the law
tests that we were talking about uh that
have an algorithm or something like that
and there's a two-prong definition
for what is an ldo adlt
so first of all it has to be a test
that's awkward or furnished by a single
laboratory and not sold for use by the
laboratory other than the original
developer so in that sense it's very
similar to the laboratory developed test
definition that we started talking about
so that's the first piece
and
in addition to that so it's first it's
got to be a test that's it's done only
by a single lab and
it has to be one of the following
it has to be an analysis of multiple
biomarkers of dna rna or proteins
combined with an algorithm
to yield a single patient-specific
result so if you put those pieces
together that sounds pretty close to uh
the definition of a mod test that we're
talking about earlier
or
it can be in addition if it's a single
test it's a
test that's done by a single laboratory
it can also be one that's cleared or
approved by the fda regardless of
whether it meets this other algorithm
requirement
and
uh
cms also has the authority to establish
other criteria
other than other than these particular
ones
so these adlts
will be like the law tests
like say
archetype dx or mammal print or
something like that
they're offered by a single laboratory
they're not sold other than
through that original developer
their analysis of rna dna
and
using a particular algorithm
now there are some significant
differences for how adlts are priced and
paid for versus other tests so first of
all until 2017 when this new process
starts they'll continue to be paid as
cross-walking or gap-filling tests
secondly
or under those methodologies
tests uh that exist today prior to 2017
will be paid based on the weighted
median of the pricing data that's
submitted by the laboratory just like
all the other tests but when a new adlt
comes on the market after 2017
um it then gets paid in a
in a very different and for medicare
somewhat unique methodology
uh it it is paid at the list price for
the first three quarters and the list
price is basically
uh the price that's determined by the
manufacturer
as the price that it is routinely
available to most payers
so for the first three quarters the
laboratory is paid that list price
at the end of the second quarter the
laboratory has to begin to submit
pricing data to from third party payers
just as everything else
and then after the first three quarters
the adlt is paid for at the weighted
median uh
of all of that reported information
and that price will continue until the
next year when the when the next uh
when the next reporting information is
submitted and the laboratory and cms
calculates the weighted median
so
uh
what is significant though
is that if that list price that is
initially used for the first three
quarters
is a hundred and thirty percent of the
weighted median
then medicare recoups that can recruit
the difference so the obviously the idea
behind that is to ensure
that uh when a new test is offered the
list price isn't set at an
unfairly or reasonably high price
now note that
it gets paid for the first three
quarters but the first three quarters
isn't defined so it's not clear whether
that's the first three quarters that the
test is ever offered or the first three
quarters after medicare begins to pay
for the test
and those are the sorts of issues that
medicare and cms are going to have to
determine
when it comes up with its rulemaking
process
there are a number of other technical
changes uh that were included in the
bill
and the bill is usually referred to as
pama by the way the protecting access to
medicare act
uh and this is all in two section 216 in
pamela
uh there are other
technical changes that are included one
is that adlts and certain other new
tests can get a hit code signed by cms
and a hate pick code is like a cpt code
but it's a process that that medicare
runs
and the idea being that it's often takes
a long time to get the cpt code you want
a code that you can use in order to um
report all of this pricing information
so
new or adlts which are currently on the
market can get a hit code so that
beginning in 2016 they can start
reporting
as we said there's a new advisory panel
that will assist
on payment and coverage issues
there are other provisions related to
the labor to the coverage process
there's a lot of concern that
some contractors especially palmetto
weren't going through the local coverage
process that medicare mandates and were
using sort of a shortcut process by
which they would just
say pretty much summarily we're not
going to pay for a particular test we
consider it screening we consider it not
medically necessary
uh and the other process is to establish
a limited number of contractors
that will deal with medicare laboratory
claims rather than the current number
which is about 12.
so there are some really really
significant things that were included in
this
in the panama legislation which will
have an impact going forward
um
and pamela will
really change the way laboratory testing
is done over the next few years as i've
said private payers are likely to follow
what medicare does
and if the prices are reduced you can
expect that private payers will also
it's
vital that organizations stay involved
there's a lot of questions still to be
answered and we expect that will happen
um
as cms comes up with these new
regulations
that completes sort of my presentation
uh i see i
folks if they have questions can ask the
questions using the question and answer
button and i think i have some questions
so i'm going to go ahead and
answer those
um so the first one is from doug at
oligos
and and the question is where will the
multi-gene panels with analytical
algorithms fall
under the new coding and reimbursement
schemes what about next-gen sequencing
so first with regard to the what we call
in the mod test these multi the
multi-analyte
analyses with algorithmic analyses
um
so as as i've said most of those will
fall under this new adlt process
um
and um
and we'll go through that adlt process
so that that will begin in 2017.
uh next-gen sequencing is sort of the
great unanswered question
uh at this particular point in time
um
it it is i it's it's the
it's the question
that's hovering over everything that
people are really only beginning to talk
about
uh and there's there's a lot of sort of
significant aspects to this um
you know i i think it is
eventually there will have to be new
codes
that will apply to next-gen sequencing i
think
uh and as that process continues then
that those things will be priced using
the various pricing methodologies that
we're talking about today
but
um it's a it's a great question and at
this point
it's it's not particularly clear
how
next-gen sequencing will fall in to this
people are beginning to talk about
there's a lot of different proposals out
there i think the other question about
next-gen sequencing to bear in mind a
little bit is
especially with regard to medicare you
know medicare only
pays for tests that are clinically
necessary and so if if you're
doing a particular test
uh or if
if if you have a particular test
medicare looks at the particular analyte
and says okay is it necessary was this
particular test necessary for this
patient
one of the big questions about next-gen
sequencing is
um
what happens if you're getting
a much broader array of information
not all of which may be necessary for
the patient at this particular time
uh and
medicare doesn't under most medicare
principles medicare doesn't want to pay
for this whole massive information it
wants to pay for the one particular
piece of information that's medically
necessary now
and that's a question that people are
really just struggling with now
and i think again it's a great question
but one that that probably won't be
answered for another year or two at most
uh the next question is
are labs held accountable for using
research reagents for clinical testing
again this is a great question
um
when fda first came out with its rules
about research use only and
investigational use only testing
it
it tried to basically say
that the manufacturer was liable if
if the laboratory used the test uh used
the reagents incorrectly and
manufacturers basically came and said
look we we have no way of knowing what
physician what the what the laboratory
is going to do with this
fda could certainly come after a
clinical laboratory that was using
something
that for that was labeled ruo and iuo
and used it using it for clinical
testing
most laboratories take the position that
they're permitted to do this under clia
and if they validate it under clia
that is appropriate the fda has never uh
totally bought that
theory
uh but at least for now it tends to look
primarily at the manufacture of the rui
or less at the laboratory
but but it's certainly an area where
they could become involved if they
wanted to
um
this is there appears to be no
consideration for what the test costs
when considering what will be paid and
why is that
well again very good question um
and
the answer that is somewhat bifurcated
so under the gap-filling process
uh that we were talking about in 2013
in fact one of the criteria that
that the contractors could use
were what is the test cost
and
labs submitted some information to
two contractors when doing that
but
but i think you know the cost of a
particular laboratory test often isn't
particularly significant and the key
part cost
that laboratories wanted contractors to
consider was what is the cost of
research and development of a new test
uh and that's and and there was
and and medicare it wasn't clear that
medicare would really take that into
account
uh and basically what medicare
usually looks at is okay well what's the
cost of actually doing the test what are
the reagent costs what are the labor
costs
what are the equipment costs
um
and
that tends to be the way that medicare
looks at these sorts of things so i
wouldn't say under the old process there
was no consideration of that but there's
a there were a lot of
concern that medicare wasn't going to
look at the full range of costs and
also a lot of laboratories were somewhat
hesitant to give cost information to uh
to contractors as well
now going forward under this new process
um
you know i i think you're right it looks
not at what the test cost to do but what
the market price is and i think the
theory behind that is basically congress
and medicare basically saying
well
you know we we should be paying what the
fair market value is of that of that
test
uh and it's very difficult for us to
look at what the cost is but we can what
we do look at is
you know what is this thing going for in
the market generally and that seems like
a an easier benchmark
of and it's a benchmark that
the government is more comfortable with
of saying okay in doing this we can we
can figure out we can look at this and
develop the price for that
um
the next is it's a lab alters and ruo
test even slightly does the test become
an ldt which can be validated and built
for compliant
uh again
this is a
a question that um
there's a lot of debate over and and
a lot of discussion about
under
clia which is the separate set of
regulations that we didn't really talk
about that much
all laboratories have to be
uh
have to have to go through certain steps
uh with regard to a new laboratory test
and under clia
uh what it basically says is if you take
this thing then you
change it or modify it then you have to
go through certain steps to validate it
uh and
some laboratories basically do take the
position that under clear they're
allowed to do that once they do that
it's a laboratory developed test they
can bill for it they've validated it
uh and that does go on
um
the
the
fda
uh hasn't really spoken out one way or
another about it although i think it's
fair to say the fda would not accept
that
probably doesn't accept that approach
its view is
basically
in that situation you're taking
something which has not been uh is not
intended for research for clinical
purposes and making it into something
for clinical purposes but that is a that
is an approach that a lot of
laboratories use and so far the fda
hasn't really taken action and said
anything definitively one way or another
and let's see the last question that i
have is
some molecular diagnostics
have variable limits of detection below
which
a result may not be clinical clinically
actionable
those tests with enhanced sensitivity
exclude themselves
from cms qualification
now i'll be honest i don't know that i
totally understand what's being asked
for here
variable limits of detection below which
those tests
i i'm not quite sure
what the point is
but let me try and answer it this way
medicare
and especially in this particular area
is very interested
in when it pays for tests
with whether or not a particular test
is clinically
useful
that is is the test providing the
physician
with some information which he can he or
she can then act on
uh and that will affect uh the clinical
outcome
for the particular patient
um
and that's
as opposed to information which might be
very interesting but really has no
clinical significance so if
you know you developed this really
incredible task
that is very very highly sensitive and a
lot more expensive than the other tests
but it doesn't really provide any
information which is more useful
to the physician
that medicare is going to say well why
are we going to pay you extra for this
when this other test is is just as good
uh and and so that's
um you know that that's i'm not sure if
that's an answer but that's the
best i can do for it i mean the
the best example of that by the way is
is the test
there's a genetic test for
uh that indicates
um
how you metabolize warfarin
and in fact the fda basically said you
know this is a test that that should be
considered for patients wearing warfarin
but medicare basically said look we
don't know that this is particularly
useful because even though
it's this test and has this great
information in fact
most physicians are telling us
that
they
don't really use this test because
basically they'll just
you know they just will do much simpler
tests and adjust the dosage of warfarin
based on that so we don't need this
really expensive test this really fancy
test we can use this other
more direct test
so i i hope that's uh an answer i'm not
like i said i'm not totally sure i
understood but
hopefully that that gives you something
some
uh idea
um
that concludes uh all of the questions
that i have i want to thank everybody
for their time i'm also supposed to let
you know that this presentation is
available to for cme credit
uh and you can go to the website that's
listed here
uh in order to
get the appropriate credit thanks uh
very much for your time
i appreciate it and
thank you again and that concludes our
presentation today thanks
you